take a look at the numbers for koh hay
he's had five starts
solid era just a little bit over four
strikeout totals have been going up
a little bit recently opponents average
kind of solid right at 268.
harihara will fire and oh another one
that could have been a strike but that's
ball
four wow that's a couple of pitches
there in fact that really could have
gone the other way two on and nobody out
let's see what jd has in mind seven home
runs he's driven in 21.
he's gonna swing immediately and tag
that one to left field heads deep
back it goes she's gone well he answered
that very quickly
in full attack mode and the red sox lead
at three to nothing
and he's able to take it there's a
slider as you can see right there
stays middle of the plate a little bit
toward the end of the back
it could have been hit farther than that
if he got the sweet spot on it but good
enough
to get it out of the ballpark and
quickly give the red sox a lead here's
xander now at a tough time last night
swing there's the drive hit the left
center field this is deep back it goes
by the boat pad and it's gone
into the bullpen a home run for xander
bogarts
martinez and bogarts go back to back and
the red sox take
a four nothing lead with nobody out in
the first inning
center fielder garcia went back and
jumped but it was just
over the eight foot fence and into the
red sox pad
in arlington the 2-2 home
to the shortstop he doesn't make many
mistakes but he makes one here
he was a gold glover at third base last
year but he boots this one finding a bit
of a groove
he gets his first strike out of the
night this one of hunter renfro the
inning is done but
the red sox post four a divali three and
two is era 4.08 coming in nathan has not
allowed a home run in his last
41 and two-thirds innings it's the
longest active streak
in the major leagues in the major
leagues
shot on the move verdugo and he'll run
it down very casually for out number one
here it comes
and he swings and drives one to right
field coming on his rent throw he's
there and makes the catch for the out
oh two and finished him very very
quickly
one two three they go red sox on top
four nothing
commanding the strike zone takes this
one out to left field calhoun is there
and that is out number one
2-0 and that's on the ground to short
and this time kind of falafel comes up
with it cleanly
two up two down in the second inning he
made it look relatively easy
caught the ball on a hop slid got under
control through striked over to first
base
he is not one of them
ground ball down to first and verdugo
retired quickly and
easily there's a bounce back inning for
kohei ari hara a
seven pitch second innings
to put him away the 3-2 and that strike
three
he froze him with the heater
3-0 pitch and that one misses so a
four-pitch walk
two men on with two outs for holt
and that ball is flared out to right
field that will get down basic
and here comes garcia he scores the
rangers have cashed one in
and a wild throw almost
created an opportunity for a second but
holt delivers against his former club
it's 4-1
jd martinez homered in the first on the
very first pitch
he saw here's the pitch to jd swinging a
drive to center field this ball is
pounded it is way back
and jd has done it again to the deepest
part of the ballpark
his second home run his ninth of the
season
and the red sox tack on a run they lead
it
five to one raphael tagged one on a line
to the right fielder gallows first time
up
they smacked that one the other way
calhoun racing back it's sailing and
that ball gets out of here too
just over the yellow line a line drive
out of here in about three seconds the
red sox
have hit their fourth home run in the
game already
mercy
here's the one two swinging a miss he
struck him out with an elevated fastball
two always gonna swing hard on this one
and drive it to right racing back renfro
he's got it
shy of the track he's spinning he is
firing
and that's gonna be a double play they
lost track of the outs
that is a double play dahl kept on
running
first pitch to the switch hitting
catcher is hit high in foul third base
side devs over near the stands does he
have room yes and he makes the catch on
the track
[Applause]
and ivaldi is out of the inning with one
man left
and avaldi
here comes radugo on the romp and he's
got it
so he's got it one thousand career
innings pitched
with two down and 97 miles an hour to
strike him out
another good frame for nate he gets it
one two three
here comes the one two from young and he
got him swinging
two away in the seventh well young is
not overpowering
you can tell by the radar gun speeds but
he's got a pretty good idea what he's
doing out there he's a veteran
if he gets this out here in the seventh
he will have pitched one two three
he will pitch four in a third again
right now he's pitched four innings
and he's only thrown 45 pitches from
korea
talked to the night about what an
international game it has become there's
a swing at a miss and
young gets the better of him here and
it's a one two three
seventh inning for the left-hander
cut on and missed he struck out another
one
0-2 pitch swinging in a miss
i think you're absolutely right and
that's what that swing said i have no
idea what's coming i don't know what's
coming is he going to throw me three in
a row
he did where he plays shortstop
that's in there for strike three very
confident darwins and hernandez strikes
out three
[Applause]
he is 4-0 with a 3-52
fly ball renfro ranging over
one away in the bottom of the ninth
one tough luck loss too swinging a miss
at a pitch away
he chased a sly that was about nine
inches off the plate
two down texas held a six hits by the
red sox pitching staff tonight
[Applause]
bounty ball right back to bryce and that
should end it the underhand flip and
that's the ball game
and that's the month red sox win it six
to one to even up the series they finish
up a fine month of april
by going 17 and 10.